in the cowshed the man in charge of the
beef herd is at least a little bit hmm
he's a big fella am i right
he's quite bigger he's a 160 160 meter
tall yeah if I saw a man like that yeah
but I wouldn't get this close to him I
don't think I would think he was on
steroids or something I think he was a
bodybuilder it is 100% natural whereby
let's say within so many generation or
readers have taken the best of the best
or the more muscle of the more muscle we
move from a normal classical type of
animal and then we select that sort of
animal based on the double Nestle and
when you say double muscle do you mean
it has to of every muscle no no no
because it looks like it does it's not
exactly the same type of muscle than any
other grid except that in terms of
quantity each of these muscle is by far
more developed
this cow is technically known as a
Belgian blue and it's the product of
selective breeding selective breeding is
the first stop on our tour of how man is
using science to control nature it's
used by farmers to enhance desirable
characteristics in their animals in fact
selective breeding is all about managing
sex to create these Belgian blues over a
hundred years farmers have only allowed
the cows and bulls with the greatest
muscle mass to mate and the result is a
bull that weighs over a ton the animals
breeders are keen to show off the
results of their hard work the Bulls are
shaved to best display their muscles
what they try to do is to keep animals
in order to highlight the the older
muscle so you can see where all the meat
is exactly exactly but even here where
they've sort of trimmed in there yeah to
highlight to highlight that muscle has
got to be high value you see and these
are all gonna be lean cuts and they're
all for quick cooking our babies right
that's right without you when you look
at this you you can't help thinking of
lunch you know is it helping the media
what the animal is as healthy as another
intensive producing animal so this is
about the most technological that we can
get not the most technological in terms
of technology we talk about selection
natural selection having achieved that
so what is the science behind the
Belgian blues there is a gene that
regulates the growth of muscles in
cattle these cows have been selectively
bred from animals that contain a copy of
this gene which doesn't work as a result
their muscles grow far larger than
normal to ensure that effective gene is
passed on sex for the Belgian blues has
been replaced by technology in the form
of artificial insemination he is a
basically a sperm machine either sperm
machine
absolutely
it's very early in the morning for the
semen is now collected is in the
artificial vagina and from there we will
process the semen in order to be able to
process artificial insemination on the
code so precise is the technology
involved they can't analyze the semen
sperm by sperm to choose the ones they
want so this is what this is testing the
sperm camp that is permanecer it's now
checking let's say the quality of the
sperm we have been collecting this
morning Green is good because you see
that they are very very mobile and they
are looking forward to to move towards
the eggs and it is enough especially
muscley sperm don't you find that they
are well they look impressive to me but
I've never seen visually you won't see
any difference there is no way to find
any difference between the bovine equine
and the the other species now right